One of the biggest challenges in machine
learning is figuring out if your data model
has a bias or a variance. Bias and variance are
related but they're two separate challenges.
Bias is the gap between your predicted value
and the actual outcome. Variance is when your
predicted values are scattered all over the place.
You can have a high bias and a low variance.
In that case, your predictions
are consistently wrong.
But even worse, you can have a high bias and a
high variance. That's when you're consistently
wrong but in a very inconsistent way.
Think of it this way. Imagine at an archery range,
an archer effortlessly let loose his five arrows,
which landed in the center of the target.
His target as a good example of low bias
and low variance. All five of his arrows were
gathered tightly in the center of the bullseye.
Another person never really shot a bow and
arrow before but seemed to have a gift for
it. He let loose his five arrows and had a
satisfying thwack as they landed on the target.
Since he was a beginner, he didn't have the
tightly grouped arrows in the target. Instead,
he had a low bias. That means that his arrows
were generally gathered around the bullseye,
but he had a high variance. There was one that
landed straight in the bullseye and the other
four were gathered in the next circle. The third
person shot five arrows, but they had a high bias
and a low variance. They were tightly gathered
in the upper right hand corner of the target.
He did shoot the arrows consistently
but he was consistently wrong.
Finally, the last person had a couple of arrows
in the corner of the target, one in the tree
behind the target, and another that landed just
in front. He had a high bias and a high variance.
His arrows were spread around the target and he
inconsistently overshot or undershot the mark.
Remember that bias
and variance are ways of measuring the difference
between your prediction and the outcome. They're
not right and wrong answers but different dials
that you need to improve your predictions.
The key thing to keep in mind is that you'll
use different techniques based on whether you
have too much bias or too much variance.
When you know which challenge you face,
you'll be better equipped to tweak your
hyper-parameters and make better predictions.